I'm David poeple or hopeful if you speak
German Dobby to pepper and from Munich
I'll keep the Aryan within so I'm and I
fit the profile bit by being a
relentless field changer everyone was
doing something that didn't want to do
undergraduate I studied cell biology and
linguistics and then I worked as an
actor completely different and and then
I needed to get a job so I went to
graduate school and I studied
neuroscience and I went back to
linguistics and so now I run a labs I'm
actually a laboratory person where the
rubber meets the road at NYU study human
brain signs and there's two kind of
things that's I've been obsessing about
for a while one that I think is probably
not so much for discussion here is the
broadly construed the temporal structure
of perceptual experiences it turns out
you think we're just kind of flowing
through the world here on a smoothly
surfing on an arrow of time the
granularity of experience is very
peculiar and you can do all kinds of
nifty tricks and other than is being
cool
I think it has some interesting
implications for what what sort of
primitive parts list is for perception
representation so if you want to see
some cool effects I can show you some
law in all kinds of nice experiments
what I worry about that's a bit more
related to the topics here is what I
call when discussions we had I work on
language in the brain and it's working
on or think about and obsess about let's
say the parts list or the granularity
problem is I am impressed
after what cognitive psychology and
linguistics philosophy and computer
science have achieved in the last
years I think it's to be taken seriously
and as a neuroscientist I'm actually
unimpressed by what we've achieved in
neuroscience so I think neuroscience has
failed for the moment as a member of the
Society for Neuroscience
I can I can say that so um the where we
were was sort of incrementally
succeeding is in what we might call the
Maps problem is we make increasingly
better Maps because we have cool
machines as experimentalist we build you
know whether it's fMRI scanner
two-photon microscopy or opt agenda we
get our tools are getting better and
better that's great so we make finer
maps in that but it's so the resolution
the same resolution the temporal
resolution of having to work is really
very impressive regrettably the
conceptual resolution it's not been so
let's say the cognitive science is
brought you know including everything
that goes under there and so very
concretely the way I view the work in my
own lab is to figure out what the parts
list is what's a view us is basically a
bunch of people in a garage like you're
taking the thing apart like a bunch of
mechanics we want to know the primitives
logical structure of the thing and it
turns out that's the mapping problem is
finding some alignments between what we
think is going on in psychology
cognitive science and neuroscience is
essentially non-existence so we have no
maybe this is a version of the the
manifest image problem reduce to a
particular common sense conception in
one sense and formal concepts but I
think I'm modestly enthusiastic that we
can make progress but I don't see how
unless we make really radical shifts in
our conceptual understanding of language
cognition more broadly as construed
study that so on and as an
experimentalist I have to translate what
we talked about casually and the things
that I can actually measure
explain characterize formalized and
that's a slightly different kind of
problem no that hasn't come up yet this
morning so and it's that's great to hear
a lot of fun
you